call them what you will be it myths
urban legends ghost stories or just full
yarns the fact is we've all heard at
least one traditionally stories like
that were just shared around a campfire
but nowadays they have ended up
spreading far and wide across internet
message boards and creepy threads
everything ranging from unsolved missing
persons cases actually being the result
of alien abductions to haunted videos
carrying an unforgiving curse or some
missing unaired episode of popular tv
shows that had somehow been unearthed by
an online sleuth we're always quick to
share these ideas these stories but deep
down a part of us knows that there's no
truth to them urban myths are
speculation that someone has turned into
a tale of terror for nothing more than
to give some quick scares to whoever
they tell it to but then that person
passes that tail on to someone else and
suddenly the story had become a
widespread legend with no discernible
point of origin sure they might still be
fictional but through sharing these
stories we as humans bring them to life
not literally of course that would be
outlandish after all when was the last
time you heard of a fictional story
becoming reality growing up with
exposure and unfiltered access to the
internet in the late 2000s paul jacobs
and his friends had been fascinated with
and admittedly pretty terrified by the
notorious legend of the slenderman it
began as whisperings in an online forum
a story that was intentionally designed
to be a modern day urban myth and just
like so many others before it the myth
spread what had started as a forum post
became unnerving photoshopped images of
a tall faceless figure in a suit lurking
in the woods next an indie video game
and even a real world tragedy given how
young he was at the time still being in
high school paul and a few others had
bought into the slenderman myth
wholesale he believed it to be real this
towering expressionless boogeyman the
more he learned about this malevolent
creature every story blog post or creepy
youtube video made about slenderman only
added more and more to his legend and
kept young paul awake at night afraid
that every noise outside his bedroom
window was the faceless horror of course
if you take away that belief the
possibility in urban legend might be
true then it simply loses its power it's
that potential that maybe towing the
line between fantasy and reality that
can allow these stories to go on and
incite fear forever but that wasn't the
case for the slenderman story and the
craze for it quickly died down after it
was debunked numerous times over casting
it permanently back into the realm of
fiction but the profound effect the
legend had on paul at a young age ended
up informing his future as he grew older
his past fear of certain stories became
a keen interest in how these tales could
influence people could any story have
that same impact or only those that
walked the line between fictional and
maybe being true did these urban legends
become more real to people because of
their subject matter or did human beings
give them that power to transcend the
constraints of fiction just by believing
in them as paul got older he began to
study the truth behind certain urban
legends attempting to trace them back to
their origins some were often inspired
by real events but with specific details
that had gradually been altered from the
original story the more and more people
passed it around ghost stories seemed to
be the most changeable but with some
roots in the real world a person might
have died a hundred years ago and the
story of them haunting their old home or
final resting place would start to
circulate then shortly after another
similar story might emerge and the two
would overlap whoever was telling each
story might have added or omitted
certain details or combined elements of
more than one tale until what was left
being passed around was neither the
first story nor the second but a hybrid
of different versions from different
storytellers there was one legend that
paul felt drawn to more than others and
it was a rather obscure one to say the
least during his self-conducted research
into stories of this nature he learned
about a tale that told of an ancient
sect called the davites according to
legends some that dated so far back that
they preceded almost all of recorded
history these devites were a callous and
cruel civilization they had emerged from
a book so the story went and sought only
to wage war on other cultures and
enslave their enemies but paul also
uncovered one detail of the story that
intrigued him more than any other it
referred to something known as the
eternal text and was regarded as some
kind of deity or figure of worship by
the devites the legend stated that this
text had helped create the book that
they had emerged from of course this all
sounded like highly fictitious nonsense
to paul jacobs he knew that things of
such nature didn't exist in the real
world they were only part of stories but
he had noticed that this particular
story seemed to have passed its way
through the ages searching further paul
had uncovered the works of an obscure
author from the united states who had
only a few works that were known about
during the 1940s and 50s even then most
of his stories weren't widely published
only a few shorter pieces making it into
a magazine that had long since stopped
being printed this writer had died in
1957 having never seen his career in
fiction come to fruition but despite his
short-lived career and being considered
a somewhat subpar author at the time the
writer's work had garnered its own
little cult following online mostly
comprised of amateur authors it was
through them that paul managed to obtain
some scanned copies of the anonymous
writer's stories particularly some that
he felt were a striking similarity to
the davide legends of the eternal text
one story in particular written in a
style lifted directly from h.p lovecraft
was based on a supposed encounter the
writer claimed to have had with
something that closely resembled the
eternal text paul also studied the
writer's own personal journals that he
had managed to recover scans of the
entries from it seemed to imply that the
author came across what he called the
written god and that this compelled him
to write a fictional version of those
events
it was only after writing about this new
encounter that what he had depicted in
his story seemed to come true
exactly as he'd written them this led to
a recursive process of the writer
creating these encounters only for them
to occur thus causing him to write about
it and then make it happen the entire
prospect not only confused and
bewildered paul but intrigued him
further as well although he had no way
of confirming what this writer had
claimed was true
paul believed that on a smaller scale
the author had achieved the same effect
that occurs during the passing down of
urban legends but the difference here
was that it had all been done through
himself via a singular person telling
variations on the same story allowing it
to continue and perpetrate recursively
of course paul didn't actually believe
in this written god or eternal text
those were all just part of the fiction
but he wanted to experiment further and
see if he could achieve the same process
for himself taking an empty notebook
paul started to write the first things
that came to mind basing a short story
off of the anonymous author's own tale
he intentionally changed a few key
details noting down things that weren't
in the original the written god appeared
behind me he wrote adding on a whim the
line it had no face the whole intention
of paul's experiment was to pass his new
version of the story onto someone else
and then try to get them to write it
from memory he wanted to observe if
their mind would change certain details
subconsciously or if they would
misremember elements when they retold
their new version if enough people could
spread the story around each time
altering or adding new parts to it what
effect could it have as he finished his
rewritten version of the author's tale
attaching it to an email to send to one
of his fellow writers paul was
blissfully unaware of just what he'd
done a heavy knocking rang out
somebody's fist pounding at the front
door loud enough to wake him bleary-eyed
paul checked the alarm clock next to his
bed it was the middle of the night
stumbling out of bed he staggered his
way towards the repetitive noise unsure
who or what would be calling this late
paul froze for a second casting his mind
back to the story he had written earlier
surely not it couldn't be right it was
just a story after all but the author he
had described how the things he'd
written had come true there it was that
possibility that maybe what if it was
behind the door right now suddenly
something much heavier than a hand
bashed against the wooden surface of the
front door causing it to fly open the
catch of the lock being ripped out of
the wall by the force of the impact a
group of black-clad figures rushed in
one of them tackling paul to the ground
before he could even process what was
happening the weight of another person
pinned him down and kept him from moving
despite his attempts at struggling free
then the feeling of something sharp
poked at the exposed skin of paul's neck
a needle filled with he wasn't sure all
he really knew right now was how dizzy
he was unable to stop himself from
slipping away the sedative quickly put
paul back to sleep as the agents filed
into his home the floor he woke up on
was freezing cold blinking his heavy
eyelids until they opened again paul did
his best to stand his head was still
spinning making it hard to keep his feet
still and to make matters worse the room
around him was hardly lit only a few low
fluorescents dimly illuminated the tiny
space mr jacobs a voice boomed over a
crackly intercom the pitch lowered to
distort it further we need you to answer
a few questions for us what paul
responded in confusion where did you
first learn about scp-582
the voice questioned barely giving paul
a moment to think about what what's an
scp
wrote
he
asked
earlier today correct boomed the unseen
speaker meekly paul nodded his head we
monitor online activity for any mentions
of scp-582
or anything using any of its known
aliases you mean that written god
eternal text thing paul replied catching
on to what the voice had been referring
to i read about it in some stories by
this old author he died ages ago most of
his work is pretty niche it's actually
hard to track down
the voice interjected bluntly when did
you specify
scp-582 would manifest manifest he
raised an eyebrow confused again it was
just a story that's what i was doing i
was examining stories and how they
change when they get passed on mr jacobs
it sounded as though the voice had
shifted still distorted but now calmer
more collected somebody else was
speaking it is important to answer our
questions your life could be very well
in danger now do you remember when you
wrote that scp-582
when it was going to appear
what do you mean in danger paul retorted
in a panic who the heck even are you
people calm down mr jacobs he looked
down to see his hands were trembling
suddenly aware of the sweat coating his
forehead paul took a series of deep
breaths trying to collect himself i
i don't remember he sighed his voice now
shaking as much as the rest of him was
the voice pressed him can you tell us
where it's going to appear i didn't
write a location either paul answered i
i just said it appeared the words he had
written earlier quickly came crashing
back into his head almost like an urgent
warning behind me as he spoke paul could
sense someone standing near him that
same sensation you get when you know
another person is in the room even when
you haven't looked directly at them yet
paul tried to keep his head forward only
tilting it slightly to the side seeing
something dark looming just behind his
shoulder he couldn't rationalize any of
what was happening he was too scared to
turn all the way around doing that would
admitted all of this was real and not
just some horrific nightmare not just a
story
[Music]
for the first time the voice over the
intercom sounded
need to turn uneasy mr jacobs telling
himself he'd wake up any second paul
rotated with his eyes screwed shut
snapping them open once he was facing
nothing a blank space lacking any
expression and all the normal features
was looming over him with an empty
eyeless stare it had no face just like
in paul's story he opened his mouth to
let out a scream only for it to be
interrupted by the crunching sounds of
neck bones twisting the wrong way as
paul's lifeless body dropped back down
to the cold floor
scp-582 vanished just as quickly as it
had arrived the thing about some
anomalies is you have to be very careful
about how you talk about them not just
because they could be listening in and
might hear you but because what you say
about them might just have a nasty habit
of coming true
that is the case with scp-582
otherwise known as its rather apt
nickname a bundle of stories what's so
fitting about that title is its accuracy
that's all
scp-582 really is
stories but therein lies its true power
this entity has a way of propagating and
perpetrating itself continuously
adapting and spreading like a mutating
virus except it doesn't pass from person
to person as an illness there are no
symptoms it transmits via stories
scp-582 is a subject to a process of
passive reality manipulation it doesn't
necessarily directly change the world
around it but can itself be changed by
certain factors what this means is
anything said or written about this
entity even if pulled out of thin air a
fictional account of its deeds all
becomes
real let's say for example you told a
story about scp-582 sneaking up behind a
foundation researcher when his back was
turned telling that story would cause
those exact events to be carried out in
the real world when scp-582 manifests it
will do so in accordance with any
details given in a fictional account
about it the same time the same place on
earth it would appear in the exact form
that the tales specified if any of those
details were omitted or purposely left
vague then the entity would still be
able to manifest and would do so in a
way that fits the rest of the narrative
appearing wherever and whenever it has
an opportunity to as far as the
researchers at the scp foundation can
tell the actual abilities of scp-582 are
usually left vague when people write
about it one of the few consistencies is
that the entity can disappear and
reappear at will to any place or time
another is that no method of harming or
even killing scp-582 has ever worked
even if written down as fiction in order
to be made fact any other details or
abilities that someone assigns to the
creature will however become a permanent
addition to its growing myth meaning it
is able to perpetually increase its
power the more people write about it on
the rare occasion multiple different
writers accounts of scp-582 contradict
each other or don't fit into the
entity's own canon it can easily adapt
to these contradictions this usually
results in conflicting information
having no effect on the bundle of
stories or having so little impact that
it is almost like they didn't happen at
all in short if one author's story
doesn't quite match up with another's
then the effect these editions have to
scp-582
and its ongoing story are lessened so
that they can all either logically occur
or be negated completely it is because
of this adaptability and that it has
been described by multiple sources that
portrayals of scp-582 tend to be
generalized this even extends down to
its appearance it's currently unknown
what the entity's true form is or if it
even has one however the fact that it is
usually depicted as a deity or god means
that this bundle of stories has been
known to manifest as one of several
avatars the most common of these
appearances is that of a humanoid being
standing well over six feet tall when
manifesting as this particular form
scp-582 is dressed in thickly layered
robes made from burlap or hessian
complete with a hood however no face is
visible underneath the creature's hood
and when presenting as this avatar it is
often described as carrying sacks of
unknown contents sometimes even
appearing to bleed heavily there have
been a number of other incarnations of
scp-582
including a six-legged form that is made
out of pure molten tar and will attack
any nearby human beings on site this
avatar would normally appear as being
fused with the first in other instances
it has appeared as a plant capable of
producing both light and enough
radiation to kill anyone in its radius
within a few hours of exposure other
times it has been a vaguely human-shaped
shadow and even has one form that exists
within more than three dimensions due to
this form existing on higher dimensions
this made it impossible to properly
perceive it with the naked eye and
resulted in the deaths of anyone who
even looked partially at it who knows
maybe at some point it has even been
described as a tall slender figure in a
dark suit with pale skin and a face with
its eyes ears nose and mouth all missing
actually it's probably best that nobody
writes it down we don't want it becoming
real now
do we the question is how can you hope
to contain or even fight something that
can be anything anywhere and have any
strength that someone claims it has well
just to be on the safe side the
foundation uses its own fictional
narrative to keep the entity contained
it is their hope that by describing it
as powerless it will turn the creature's
own reality altering properties against
it and actually cause
scp-582 to lose its abilities what
thoughts if any that flow through that
alien mine are not mine to know it
remains silent and still within its
chamber entrenched in the persistence of
its own memory it remains but only as a
shade of what it was its power spent or
at least come to rest so remember
scp-582 possesses no actual
consciousness or free will anything it
has ever said or done is because someone
wrote that it would and yes we're only
saying that because we don't want to
write that it's broken free from
containment and is currently standing
behind you if we did that it might just
come true
now go and check out scp-023 the black
shock for another anomalous entity that
has slipped its way into the zeitgeist
of mythology and legend or if you're
looking for more monsters of memetic
madness then why not get yourself
acquainted with scp-2440
the sealed king